bonjour bonjour comment ça va il fait
beau il fait chaud aujourd'hui on est le
neuf et on né le 9 février on n'est pas
vraiment le 9 février au moment où je
tourne mais moment où cette vidéo sort
c'est le 9 février 2022 pourquoi et bien
parce que le 9 février 2022 samsung nous
révèle sa nouvelle gamme s pour l'année
2022 au sans doute rail comme ça me
souviens bien joué au niveau des noms en
2020 dont l'un des smartphones s22 et ça
c'est chouette alors aujourd'hui on
vient se parle des samsung galaxy s 22
ultra ici dans cette vidéo je vous parle
dans une autre vidéo des samsung galaxy
s 22h22 plus aujourd'hui au centre par
l'h2s 22 ultra où je vais y arriver
alors 16 22 le trac sont chouettes et
son chouette pourquoi et bien parce que
les 22 ultra ils prennent le relais
d'une gamme qu'on avait trouvé pour la
dernière fois en 2020 ben ouais souvenez
vous c'était la gamme not a gangsta
était chouette pourquoi et bien parce
qu'elle avait un style et que c'était la
gamme de la productivité donc
aujourd'hui on a des gammes qui seront
un peu plus simple un peu plus écrite
c'est à dire la gamme s20 restera
toujours la gamme photos et vidéos mais
à des prix modèle ultra on vient flirter
du côté de la productivité c'est très
assumé c'est très clair avec un très
grand écran incurvé avec un design qui
est très différent très atypique et très
chouette ça j'aime beaucoup ça me plaît
énormément et puis avec un espagne alors
on va se poser plein de questions est ce
qu'on va venir acheter ce smartphone
parce qu'on veut ce qui se fait de mieux
en termes d'écrans s convient à ses
smartphones parce qu'on veut ce qui se
fait de mieux chez samsung toujours en
termes de productivité est ce qu'on
vient d'acheter parce qu'on veut ce qui
se fait de mieux en terme de photos et
vidéos ou est ce qu'on vient d'acheter
parce qu'on veut un aspect nous ou alors
est-ce qu'on va rester parce qu'on veut
un peu tout ça c'est la bonne question
et si vous ne voulez pas de l'espagne
sous le coup de l'acheter fabre a brillé
il ya plein de questions qui se posent
et on va essayer d'y répondre tout de
suite oui tout de suite maintenant dans
cette vidéo avant le thé c'est dans
quelques jours que je vous invite à
venir vous abonnez vous cliquez sur le
petit bouton rouge si les rouges que
vous n'êtes pas abonné vous actionnez la
cloche comme ça vous serez notifié dès
que la prochaine vidéo notamment d'être
la vidéo du test arrivera c'est
vachement cool aujourd'hui on les
découvre on va les tester ah ouais c'est
but sans doute ravi surtout si on a
plein de couleurs ils sont en blanc ils
sont regardés comme ça en anthracite
tout sympa aussi on l'a dans un petit
bordeaux
cool aussi et puis dans un petit verre
un petit verre un peu un peu bleus voilà
bref c'est chouette c'est parti pour une
vidéo pour découvrir ensemble et nouveau
samsung galaxy s 22 le trail en il a
maintenant
[Musique]
ok ok on revient ici on revient l'été
chez samsung maintenant arrivé quelques
jours plus tard et on est au studio ici
alors tout de suite au moment où je vous
le dis à plusieurs vidéos qui sont
sortis une série samsung galaxy s 22 s
22 plus celle ci que vous aurez tout de
suite sur le modèle ultra puis sur les
tablettes les tablettes compte annoncer
hab et suite s suit plus elle suit ultra
également à découvrir sur ma chaîne
youtube tout de suite mettant donc
allez-y c'est pas déjà fait puis bien
évidemment abonnez-vous pour tout savoir
de la tutelle des nouveautés on va se
faire les thèses de tout sens à tout
regarder mais on va se mettre tout de
suite on sépare du samsung galaxy s 22
ultra le grand modèle de très grands
modèles 2 129 g grand est un peu lourd
oui mais bon c'est normal parce que
c'est un très gros smartphone et surtout
c'est un form factor qui changent parce
que si vous avez regardé le s20 ultra et
le s 21 ultra l'année dernière il avait
à peu près le même facteur là c'est
différent parce qu'en fait ça qui va
choix intéressant c'est qu'avec ce s22
ultra samsung officialise la mort de la
gamme dot tout simplement voilà en voir
la gamme qui sortait à doute fin juillet
août elle est terminée elle verra plus
jamais le jour pourquoi parce que déjà
ils ont patienté une dernière donc
c'était vraiment déjà annonciateur et
puis surtout qu'est ce qu'on voit
arriver là eh bien on va tout simplement
arrivé à samsung galaxy s 22 traquer un
stylet intégré un très grand smartphone
avec un style intégré c'est en gros un
smartphone de la gamme note sauf que oui
et non parce que la gamme s et samsung
c'est la gamme photo vidéo ce smartphone
là le f-22 ultra est également un
produit dédié photo vidéo mais et grâce
au stylet productivité productivité de
par votre smartphone et de par la
performance qui vous permet d'abord à
toutes les applications qui vont arriver
derrière mais en plus le style et
l'écriture alors pour autant si ce
smartphone vous intéresse par ses
caractéristiques différentes des f 22 et
f 22 plus eh bien vous n'êtes pas obligé
d'utiliser le respecte alors vous pouvez
l'utiliser pour lire écrire pour venir
décider mais vous pouvez également
l'utiliser comme une petite télécommande
avec les airs jester vous venez vous
actionnez le bouton pour venir
déclencher une photo à distance vous
pouvez venir prendre des notes n'aura
pas mal de choses avec le espana sa
trace alors moi je suis pas forcément
clients du respect parce que j'utilise
palestine et mais je peux comprendre que
ça intéresse pas mal de monde que ce
soit vraiment intéressant vraiment
passionnant puis une petite télécommande
comme ça pour dégager de la photo que
nous quand on est à distance et ben ça
peut être vraiment cool alors on a
vraiment et on le voyait déjà sa tous
l'avaient déjà montrer un petit peu de
produits qui prenait qui tourne et hop
là comme par magie on a 20 qui apparaît
surtout comme si il est très différent
la forme est différente ne serait-ce
qu'au niveau du bloc photo on le voit
l'arrière le blog photo est dingue il
est complètement intégrée au smartphone
on ajuste les objectifs qu'ils sortent
cinq objectifs ça change ça change je
vous l'avais déjà montré là il ya
quelques jours que sur la vidéo de
rumeurs c'était le modèle laquelle est
futée c'était vraiment dingue alors en
france il va arriver dans quatre
couleurs la couleur bordeaux le noir le
vert et le blanc d'eau qui est
totalement en aluminium et puis quand on
emprunte ultrasonique sous les crampons
ça c'est plutôt bien alors l'écran
parlement parce qu'il est intéressant
vous avez un écran dynamique amoled 2 x
et techno qu'on avait déjà à l'année
dernière sauf que là en plus nous ont
rajouté ce qu'ils appelleront le vision
booster alors déjà on a ici un espace
colorimétrique 100% dci p3 hockey direct
mais surtout ce qui fâche notre axe
vision booster c'est qu'on monte jusqu'à
accrochez vous bien accrochez vous
obtenez vous quelque chose parce que la
renverse
1759 wahou
1758 je passe ça vous parle ces chiffres
mais c'est juste aujourd'hui le truc le
plus dingue que j'ai vu sur un
smartphone la luminosité le pic de
luminosité le plus haut donc c'est un
smartphone que lorsque vous serez à
l'extérieur ne devrait pas vous lâcher
alors on va se tester nos quelques temps
n'ont une fois de plus abonné vous c'est
pas déjà fait pour va regarder ça en
plein jour on va grâce à la nuit parce
qu il se peut aussi que la nuit ce que
vous éclaire un peu tellement qu'est la
luminosité à
1759 ça c'est à grasse et je vous le dis
aux visions booster alors après ils ont
mis le paquet ils ont été très loin des
coteaux de rafraîchissement adaptatif on
va jusqu'à 120 hertz mais sur les ultras
et uniquement sur l'ultra haut part de
hertz sur un horizon de 10 km ça lorsque
votre smartphone est tout noir à qui
ajustent leur décris dessus jusqu'à 120
hertz et lorsque vous serez en train de
regarder un film qui ne cite pas du son
baiia 1 vous serez plus bas permettra
d'économiser la batterie et on a
également une taux d'échantillonnage
tactile de 240 air sont ça plutôt bien
pour le gaming soir que lorsque vous
allez venir l'utiliser et puis appuyer
un peu partout et bien que sa réponse
très rapidement que vous avez une
expérience qui soit vraiment fluide
alors on vient également lutter contre
la lumière bleue ici avec de
l'intelligence artificielle aussi et
puis tout qu'est jacques est vraiment
marrant et la différence par rapport aux
magasins de plus cet écran curve est il
est incurvé dans les autres smartphones
l'écran est plat là il est réellement un
curve r je sais qu'à plein de personnes
qui n'aiment pas les écrans incurvés
qu'ils iront web écoutez moi j'en sais
rien samsung galaxy s 22 ultra un écran
incurvé un style et un gros smartphone a
quasiment de 130 grammes j'en sais rien
mais il y en a plein d'autres qui seront
amoureux et qui aimeront cet écran
incurvé l'écran incurvé sa paroisse
apporte un peu plus de profondes enfin
plus droit enfin ton âge pas rien tout
cas j'aime bien moi qui les croient
encore et ça me plaît bien goûter
pourquoi pas et puis en plus un truc
intéressant c'est que vous avez un corps
nu réglages et dictus à l'avant mais
également à l'arrière et ici on a un
châssis qui est en aluminium comme ça à
votre smartphone il est protégé de tous
les côtés ça c'est plutôt bien avoir un
bel écran c'est bien mais il faut venir
le protéger et oui vous me voyez venir
c'est donc aujourd'hui deux vidéos qui a
réalisé en partenariat avec green au
chili et je vous le mets dans le mille
pourquoi pas parce que votre écran et
votre smartphone en règle générale il
faut venir le protéger pour éviter même
si les résistants les déconvenues
lorsqu'il va tomber pour ne pas venir
l'endommager et regarder sur le site de
rhinau schyle il vous l'annonçait déjà
samsung galaxy s 22 alors il vous parle
pas de tous les modèles parce qu'au
moment où je fais cette vidéo et bien
ils n'ont pas encore été officialisés
bah oui parce que je la sors au moment
où les smartphones sont officielles mais
si vous voulez tout savoir me regarde et
vous avez qu'à descendre ici vous
inscrivez alors nous lecteurs et vous
serez informés et puis revenez un camp
l'a tous eu d'ailleurs la vidéo est
sortie donc revenir sur l'île de rhinau
sheed vous allez avoir les protections
d'écran sahir coque protection d'écran
pour ce samsung galaxy s 22 vous allez
jeter un coup d'oeil directement dessus
parce que vous verrez tout mais moi je
peux vous montrer des choses vachement
intéressante alors chez rhinochill vous
avez quoi vous avez des coques de
protection avec des design personnalisé
j'ai voulu dans quelques instants et
c'est vachement intéressant parce qu'il
ya plein de collaboration effectivement
aujourd'hui chez rideau chine dans
différents univers regardez jean sérien
disney classique si vous aimez disney on
va aller jeter un petit coup d'oeil vous
allez voir quels atouts qui sont hyper
sympa on va retrouver quoi les
aristochats on va retrouver le roi lion
on va retrouver quoi la loi c'est quoi
ça c'est lilo et stitch les 101
dalmatiens bref tous les classiques de
disney sont ici mais ça ne s'arrête pas
là puisque on va retrouver des coques
star wars regardez là j'adore ces
derniers sont super cools avec l'étoile
de la mort vous avez les work vous avez
quoi bon avoir trouvé dark vador les
droïdes enfin je trouve ça super bowl al
superbe recom salle avec les je parlais
pas le nom de ces vaisseaux enfin bref
il y en a vachement c'est hyper hyper
hyper hyper joly j'adore celui-là vadder
is my motivator ouais ok puis vous avez
one piece vous avez marvel dragon ball
france rugby disney pixar disney mickey
g2 ils se portent dragon ball z batman
demande alors un dingue pour citer
qu'eux il ya la nasa league of legends
pac man rick est morte il le psg la nba
hello kitty friends enfin bref on a
tellement my rock à damian squeeze
également vibre qu'un il y en a tous les
côtés voilà gotha cas je vous passe un
peu l'histoire donc si vous voulez dire
protégé ici votre smartphone dans les
meilleures conditions ce que je vous
invite à faire et bien c'est bien cliqué
sur le lien que vous avez en bas dans la
description ayant trouvé le code grevin
de grr 22 permet d'avoir 5 % de remise
sur l'achat de tout ce que vous voulez
sur le site de rhinau chine et ça c'est
vachement bien et merci à rhinau schild
alors se tourner cette vidéo alors si
c'est forcément un smartphone où on va
avoir des haut parleurs stéréo on s'en
doutera mais si on veut la meilleure
expérience on fait quoi et bien on va
utiliser ces galaxies bugs y en a plein
chez samsung galaxy buzz on va par la
galaxie bleus se prenant quelques
instants parce qu'ils font partie de
l'offre de lancement mais on dirait que
instant est ici à savoir vous avez du
blue tooth 5.2 ok mais le truc vachement
intéressant et je vous en ai parlé dans
la vidéo de rumeurs alors on le sait ça
a été officialisée samsung a présenté
officialisé en début d'année son nouveau
processeur gravé en catalan omet l'exil
aux 2200 et l'exil aux 2200 m ait
beaucoup pourquoi et bien parce qu'il a
été développé le gpu pour la partie
graphique en partenariat avec amd donc
un gros focus sur le gaming on va donc
se dire qu'ici ce smartphone il devra
être très loin en terme de performance
justement au niveau du gameplay alors ça
on le verra pas ce qu'il ya toujours une
grosse différence avec une partie pour
l'europe et une grande partie du monde
qui sort avec l'exil aux 2200 et puis
pour une petite partie de l'asie et puis
le nord amérique le canada et les usa
sortira avec le sa dragonne 8 de
première génération donc on verra lequel
va aller le plus loin peut-être le stand
rigole mais c'est ça qui est vachement
intéressant c'est partie gpu qui est
développé en partenariat avec amd
la vie ça va tartinez ça vraiment
envoyer du bois alors au truc qui est
vachement cool et sans doute rassurant
smartphone comme ça qu'un grand écran
c'est une très grosse batterie de 5000
millions terreur qui si samsung a fait
un truc vachement bien installés ils ont
augmenté la vitesse de charges avant
plafonnée à 25 watts aujourd'hui on
monte à 45 watts et de la recharge
rapide alors me direz-vous ça c'est bien
mais le bloc de charges n'est toujours
pas inclus il faut venir elle a acheté
en plus sur le site de samsung et s'il
vous intéresse avec le produit que megan
évidemment tous les liens en bas dans la
description et puis en plus pendant la
charge sans fil 15 watts ok également le
bloc de charge sans fil 15 mois qu'il
n'ait pas inclus à noter que sur le s 22
vous avez de la recharge max en rapide
25 watts et retarde us 22 plus est sur
le modèle ultra que vous avez de la
recharge 45 watts côté logiciel on
tourne sur one way 4.1 basé sur
l'android 12 j'ai déjà parlé de
l'expérience one day 4 j'ai fait une
vidéo justement toutes les astuces en
vous expliquant les nouveautés donc une
fois de plus je vous mets le lien je
sais pas peut-être ici ou alors en bas
dans la description aller jeter un petit
coup d'oeil ça sera vachement
intéressant qu on va paraître la partie
photo parce que je voulais dire à gabès
et la gamme photo vidéo alors on reprend
un peu le secours n'avaient déjà sur la
gamme s 21 ultra l'année dernière on
améliore tout ça les gens va retrouver
effectivement ce capteur 8 mégapixels
avec autofocus dual pixels avec bien
évidemment une stabilisation optique en
ouvre à f 1.8 ok ça me paraît logique on
a un ultra grand-angle de 12 mégapixels
f 2.2 avec un champ de vision de 120° ok
bon ça me paraît bien ce catalan sayah
double tel objectif alors on a un
premier objectif de 10 mégapixels avec
un zoom optique x 3 couvre f 2.4 bien
mais le deuxième est plus cool toujours
10 mégapixels zoom optique x 10 alors là
l'ouverture tout c'est pas tout à fait
la même f 4.9 intentions faible
luminosité ça sera quand même pas
terrible terrible et on peut monter
jusqu'à ce pays zoom x 100 à vouneuil
internet sur infodis optique le clan
fois sans vous montrez vraiment
numérique mais a priori ça sera
améliorée a priori le space zoom x 100
il serait quand même de meilleure
qualité déjà parce que vous avez un
nouveau processeur derrière un exil aux
2200 qui permettra d'avoir de meilleures
capacités de calculs et on nous
annonçait aussi de lier à derrière qui
viendra réellement amélioré plan ils
vont pas faire de la magie n ont pas
venir créer des choses que vous n'avez
pas besoin que sur un zoom optique x 10
mai je veux bien croire que le nouvel
exynos eliya derrière ça améliore un
petit peu la sauce on verra ça lors du
test d'un évidemment tout en sachant
qu'ici vous avez des pixels puis à je
pense pas du grand temps mais son tour
en forme 8 mégapixels xl plus large de
2,4 micromètres donc ils vont capter
plus de lumière en plus ici font quoi
ils font du pixel baning la techno c'est
le pixel adaptative en fait ils vont
prendre plus pixel capic c'est pour
faire un seul même les gros pixels et
vous permettre d'avoir alors une photo
probablement sorti en 12 mégapixels donc
plus de 500 têtes du neuf pixels en un
an fin à calculer de tête comme ça 49
pixels en a je pense qu ils vont prendre
9 pixels faire un seul même les gros
pixels captera plus de lumière qui
ressentira une photo en 12 mégapixels
d'excellente qualité qui sera bien
meilleur en conditions de faible
luminosité donc ça aussi c'est le gros
point positif puis là vous avez un
nouvel i s p ait pu booster l ia comme
diraient les américains raillait speed c
est l image sensing processeur cell le
processeur d'image en fait donc un
nouveau processeur d'image parce que
vous avez forcément un nouveau
processeur qui fait partie de l'exil aux
2200 donc qui permettra d'aller plus
loin en termes de capacités de calcul
pour vos photos vous avez également
notre focus avec de l'ia pour améliorer
la netteté puis à pas mal de petites
innovations contre sortie il ya un
ajustement du framerate les framerate
c'est le nombre d'image par seconde et
vous avez du hdr 12 bits pour de la
vidéo on aime ça va tartiner un axe et
puis vous avez plein de nouveaux modes
nouveaux modes portrait vidéo on verra
ça j'ai jamais été bien hype et par le
mode portrait vidéo souvent ça détour
est pas terriblement on verra ce avec un
proche gravé en kata d'omettre faire des
choses un petit peu mieux ou pas on aura
également du portrait nuit on aura
également du portrait zoomer de nuit on
regardera tout ça une fois de plus lors
du test mais en tout cas ce qu'on nous
annonce issime paraître assez alléchant
au niveau de la photo mais également au
niveau de la vidéo puis je vous lise
ayant espen est ce qu'on vient ici
travailler sur la productivité avec un
aspect de votre stylet avec une latence
qui a été réduite par trois par rapport
au samsung galaxy note 20 ultra le
dernier samsung galaxy note sortir tout
le plus haut de gamme dans cette
génération là avec une latence réduite
donc on se testera tout ça alors bien
évidemment vous avez ce qu ennemi
aujourd'hui du wifi 6e eux même si on a
pas partout de wifi 6e surtout chez nous
mais bon en tout cas il est déjà prêt on
a de la 5g forcément on a de l'ultra
wide band et notamment pour utiliser vos
smarttags et smarttags plus du nfc pour
samsung taille pour le paiement
dématérialisé c'est un smartphone qui
est certifié ip 68 résistants à l'eau et
à la poussière et puis surtout qu est un
peu différent cette année c'est la
première fois on n'a pas d'écouteurs
c'était la loi française qui oblige
c'est vraiment l'exception française qui
obligeait les fabricants à mettre des
écouteurs filaires directement à
l'intérieur de leur boîte de smartphones
pour se dire ok mieux vaut téléphoner
avec des écouteurs filaires et met le
smartphone un peu plus loin distances
pour venir se protéger des ondes et bien
la loi a changé les constructeurs n'ont
plus l'obligation par rapport à un
besoin écologie donc on se dit que pour
l'écologie bien on prendra le téléphone
à l'oreille ou alors on achètera même
ses propres écouteurs ça peut faire
râler alors rassurez vous les écouteurs
sont pas inclus dans la boîte mais vous
avez une offre de précommande avec des
galaxies bugs pro offert et ça c'est
vachement cool donc ce à partir de
maintenant pouvez y aller alors je vous
donne les tarifs du produit après je
vous parle les offres de précommande
offre de lancement de plus tôt ça sur le
site de samsung vous avez deux config
828 qui coûte 1200 59 euros c'est certes
un petit budget j'ai triomphé sur la
gamme note mais on est sur le s 22 ultra
et puis vous avez une config plus boosté
en termes de ram on passe de 8 à 12 il
ya drame c'est quand même pas
négligeable et on passe de 128 go de
stockage à 256 go de stockage attention
ici non extensible à 1359 euros c'est
quand même plutôt pas mal et en plus de
ça en plus des galaxies buzz pro offert
vous avez en plus de la valeur de
reprise de votre smartphone si vous
faites reprendre votre smartphone et
bien samsung rajoute 150 euros en plus
de valeur de reprise donc le truc est
vachement intéressant ce qui fait que
j'en sais rien moi si vous avez un
smartphone à 400 ou 300 et 400 euros à
faire reprendre et bien en fait vous
repartez avec un budget déjà de 550
euros qui se déduisent du prix de votre
smartphone donc à les calculatrices
monsieur gros nazi fait péter le boulier
ce qui fait que regarder on verra les
450 ornières 550 euros si je me prends
la version à 1359 euros - 450 euros je
sais je suis une [ __ ] au calcul mental
ça vous le sort 1 909 euros ça reste
quand même beaucoup d'argent mais malgré
tout c'est quand même beaucoup mieux
donc ça c'est cool donc voilà tout ce
que je peux vous dire je me sens aux
smartphones moi je les prie en main j'ai
trouvé intéressant j'ai trouvé un peu
grand un peu lourd mais une fois plus on
est sur le modèle ultra c'est normal
j'ai pas eu le temps de faire des photos
je les prix trop rapidement en main mais
c'était une découverte donc ce
smartphone on en reparlera très bientôt
lors du test on va aller le voir sur le
terrain on va l'essayer on va dessiner
on va griffonné on va partager on va
faire des photos on va aller se filmer
avec on va regarder ce qu'ils racontent
tout ce qu'ils racontent on va regarder
aussi si les bons gaming justement avec
ce nouveau processeur exynos 2200 on va
regarder s'il est bon divertissement qui
en doutent pas un je connais la qualité
des dalles de samsung je sais que
dynamique amoled 2 x ça marche vachement
bien mais tout s'en va regarder et on va
le tester sur le terrain donc ça c'est
génial donc pour tout savoir on fait
quoi eh bien on s'abonne et si d'ici là
vous avez des questions vous voulez des
choses que je regarde en particulier
lors du test voulu marquer dès
maintenant en bas en commentaire je
prendrais tous vos commentaires en
considération j'irai tester sur le
terrain et je regarderai si vous avez
des moindres un peu particulière alors
demandes farfelues s'abstenir mais
j'irai voir d'ici là bas vous bien que
j'embrasse toutes vos questions en bas
en commentaires beaucoup d'amour pour
les soins de vous à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]